Welcome back to the show, remember the
number one way to support the worth? We do.
Grab a membership, join Pacman
dot com. Easy, quick. Feels good.
No reason not to do it. We are going to
hear from some folks. There are people
aching to get on the air with me today via
The David Pakman Show official discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. That's DIY c NOM's DHS
COPD. Let's start today. There are just so many
people. It's hard to know where to start. Let's
start with Mel from Florida. Mel from Florida.
You're on the air.
Mel, Florida, we can hear you.
Yeah, awesome. Hi, David. Hi.
So I was playing around with five thirty eights.
You know, where you change the states around
on the electoral map? Yeah. And it looks like
even without knowing if he gets Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin and Michigan, I have his
chance of winning just two above.
Ninety nine percent. If he just picks up Florida.
Yes. So we were going through some of these
scenarios. So what one of the big things
that happened this week is the Supreme Court
decided that Pennsylvania will continue counting
ballots received all the way up until three days
after Election Day. And there if we imagine for
a second, we won't know Pennsylvania on election
night. There are a whole bunch of scenarios where
if Biden is able to take Wisconsin and Michigan
and nothing else, the election will be determined
by Pennsylvania. If Biden takes Florida but not
Wisconsin and Michigan, the election will be
determined by Pennsylvania. But what you're
accurately pointing out is if Biden takes Florida,
it's unlikely that that's the only change from
2016. I think if Biden takes Florida, he almost
certainly gets Wisconsin and or Michigan.
That would make Pennsylvania unlikely to
be the deciding state. And you are very,
very much on on board, which is if Biden gets
Florida, it's it's difficult to imagine a path
for him to lose. Although flipping Florida alone
is not actually enough for Biden to get the 270.
Right. Yeah.
That's what I was looking
at. I just saw that because it's such a big
state. Yeah, and it is kind of, you know, in its
singable. So guess I was wondering what
your take on that would be. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I agree. It's so we have to understand
the math is Florida alone isn't enough.
The reality is if Biden wins Florida, he
probably at least gets either Arizona, Wisconsin
or Michigan, in which case I believe it would be
enough. And Pennsylvania. Note no longer matters.
Thank you. Yeah, I was I was all
I really was wondering about,
because, of course, that's I'm in that state. Yes.
How did you already. Did you vote
early by mail or what did you do?
No, I'm actually going to vote on Election Day.
OK? In part because I want to make sure that there
isn't anybody hounding people at the polls. Right.
Yeah. And if there is if you can safely film
it and get me the video, we will be covering
that. Intimidate, intimidation and the like.
Oh, yeah, absolutely. All right, Mel.
Thank you so much. Thank you. All right.
Mel from Florida voting in person. Very,
very exciting stuff going on there.